now an actual fact we haven't discovered
a huge amount about obesity genes at the
moment but you know they're almost
certainly years and we know that there
are genes involved in the development of
predisposition to diabetes and so on and
we know that diabetes is going to become
a massive problem over the next set of
20 to 30 years ago estimates in the
range of 400 million people with
diabetes by 2030 around the world and
what were what we would like to
understand is how does your genetic
predisposition interact with your
environmental predisposition to you know
culture what what kind of foods that you
eat you know etc etc and that's the
piece that we want to try and you know
understand and sort of tease apart and
what for diabetics what does that mean
in terms of your likelihood of getting
cardiovascular disease and so on so I
think those are the areas in which is
going to be a lot of work to try and
sort of understand the differences in
populations and the differences in rates
of obesity between different populations
how much of that is genetic how much of
it is environment and what can one do
together to get around the other so what
kind of lifestyle changes can you make
to get around your genetic
predisposition to get developing obesity
and and also what kind of behavioral
components might make it difficult or
easy for you to do that you know because
it's often very difficult for people to
change their lifestyle and that's where
that's where it's often the big
challenge so we all know what we're
supposed to do in order to keep healthy
most of the time but it's difficult to
do
you